CBS News has confirmed CIA director Mike
Pompeo met yesterday with Palestinian
President Mahmoud Mahmoud Abbas it came
a day before Israeli Prime Minister
Benjamin Netanyahu's White House meeting
today with President Trump this is
Netanyahu's first visit after years of
frosty relations with President Obama
Jen Crawford is in Washington with how
the president's advisor and son-in-law
Jared Kushner is playing a key role in
shaping Trump administration foreign
policy Jen good morning oh good morning
so Jared Kushner has really emerged as a
quiet force in the Trump White House he
serves as a main conduit with foreign
contacts in Mexico China Canada among
others but when it comes to Israel in
the Middle East the stakes are
especially high and for Kushner it's
also personal if you can't produce peace
in the Middle East
nobody can President Trump declared that
his son-in-law Jared Kushner could
broker the toughest deal in the world
lasting peace between Israelis and
Palestinians
Jared's agenda is not confused it's
perfectly aligned with the president
critics point out that the 36 year old
businessmen and husband of Ivanka Trump
has no government or foreign policy
experience the Trump family friend and
real estate mogul Thomas Barak says
that's an asset so you take his mind his
ability his dedication his focus in a
fresh basis without a preconceived
notion are actually better than having
somebody who was in foreign policy for
60 years foreign leaders initially were
skeptical of Kushner says the Washington
Post Phillip Rucker they sort of assumed
he's probably in over his head he might
be a spoiled kid of the president and
yet he's been very impressive to them
Rooker says Kushner has been pivotal in
shaping the u.s. his relationship with
Mexico Jared Kushner led the Mexican
Foreign Minister into the Oval Office
where they talked to President Trump and
they advised him to tone down his
rhetoric about Mexico President Trump
did just that in a speech we also
understand that a strong and healthy
economy in Mexico is very good for the
United States but Kushner's Council was
short-lived it was the next morning of
course where Trump went on Twitter and
got into a feud with the President of
Mexico
and the whole thing seemed to blow up
Kushner's value according to Thomas
Barak lies in his ability to listen and
distill information and to do so without
an agenda he understands how the
president thinks probably better than
anybody and most importantly to the
president he's trustworthy
critics say Kushner an Orthodox Jew is
pushing Trump toward a more hardline
stance on Israel but no administration
over the course of four decades has been
able to solve the arab-israeli conflict
Barracks says with a new set of leaders
in the arab world wanting a solution the
timing is right israel aligned with
tolerant islam is the answer and i think
that that's what jared is pushing
towards trying to use those
relationships in a clean canvas with his
influence on the president to say have a
soft hand be culturally sensitive this
would be an opportunity for you mr.
president to maybe do something along
the lines of what President Reagan
Maggie Thatcher did in bringing down the
wall now in advance of today's White
House meeting Kushner at dinner last
night with Netanyahu and Secretary of
State Rex Tillerson we don't expect
there to be any policy pronouncements
about the peace process coming out of
today's meeting though Iran will be at
the top of the agenda Gayle all right
thank you Jim